[MUSIC PLAYING]
GOPAL ASHOK: So the whole--
if you just look at the
application ecosystem today,
I think it's very
fair for us to say
that there are some
fundamental characteristics
that the applications
that we build today have.
Regardless of whether
you're building
a departmental application or
an internet scale application,
the speed and the response
time for applications
are super important
in today's world.
You couple that with
scale, you couple that,
and you add high availability.
And you add the need to run
application infrastructure
at a certain operational cost.
It becomes a very
interesting problem.
So when it comes
to caching, why is
caching such a
fundamental infrastructure
when it comes to applications?
Caching is not a new concept.
Everybody uses caching.
From our perspective,
the use cases
that we see when we see
customers use caching,
primarily is around two
high level use cases.
One is the obvious
one, which is latency.
You want to reduce latency
of the application.
You want to have an
in memory caching
layer in between
your application
layer and your database layer.
That's the main use case.
The other one that we
also see customers use
is to reduce cost.
So you can argue that if you
have a back end database where
you are charged at 40 ops per
second, or the number of ops
that you are using for the back
end, a caching layer in between
can actually help
you reduce cost.
So that's one of the
other use cases that we
see customers use, or the
benefit that customers
try to get out of caching.
But the second use case
or that second benefit
is kind of tricky
because you have
to be very careful in terms
of how you slice your cache
and not get into this whole
notion of a Thundering Herd
problem.
If part of the
cache goes down, do
you have enough capacity
on the back end, et cetera.
So that's a specific
case where you
want to be super careful
in terms of how you
design your caching and system.
But when you look
at the use cases,
and there's a whole
bunch of them,
I mean literally across all
different types of applications
caching is used.
And I don't think we need
to elaborate on that.
But the whole idea
is that you have
a cache in your
application structure
so that the data
access layer can
get that frequently accessed
data from memory rather
than from disk.
But there's a whole
bunch of things behind it
in terms of how to
optimally build a cache.
And we'll talk more about that.
From a caching
pattern perspective,
I would say the read through
cache is fundamentally
what everybody uses mostly.
Which essentially
says that, hey, go
try to get the data from cache.
If it's not there, go
read it from the database.
And once you read from
the database, cache it,
so that subsequent queries can
get the data from the cache.
So that's kind of the
fundamental caching pattern
that most applications use.
But then we also see write
through caching patterns.
How many of you use
write through today?
Or any implementation
of write through?
So write through is
an interesting case
where it is supposed to
solve a lot of the problems
around cache consistency.
But it is a complex logic and
there are issues that comes,
or consistency issues
that can crop up.
And there are a lot
of error conditions
that you need to watch out for.
So essentially write
through a caching
means you write to
the cache first,
and then write to the
back end database.
And you only commit once the
writes are in both the places.
And write behind essentially,
which is very, very rarely used
means you just write
to the cache first,
and then you lazily write
into the back end database.
So that's an eventual
consistency model.
And any eventual
consistency model
it really depends
on your application.
So if your application can
tolerate that kind of a model,
great.
But the other one that we
also see is in process.
So what I mean by in
process is that if you want
to have an application close
to you, or a cache close
to your application node
for example, you can have,
for example, a Redis
process running directly
in your application node
to cache like local data.
So the reason I bring
that up in this context
is because sometimes when you
have a managed service that
gives you a managed Redis,
which is kind of a distributed
centralized cache, the in
process caching use case
you may be better off just
deploying your own Redis along
with, for example,
if you're running GKE
and if you are running your
application node in GKE,
it may be better off just
running Redis directly
in the node rather than using
a centralized management
managed cache.
But these are some of the
different varying caching
patterns that we see.
So why Redis?
I think everybody
knows about Redis.
But I think just to
quickly summarize,
we all know Redis is a very
versatile in-memory data store.
It is categorized
as key value store.
But there are so many
different uses of it
that I feel it is more than
just a key value store.
But if you look at the
key capabilities of Redis,
from-- just forget
about the latency part,
which is pretty obvious.
But the data structure is one
of the most powerful aspects
of Redis.
Like there are all
kinds of different data
structures that allows
you to efficiently process
data for various use cases.
And I'll touch upon
that a little bit.
But the other things like high
availability and persistence
also make it a lot more usable
for different use cases.
And I'll talk about these
characteristics and the use
cases in just a bit.
There's capabilities like
Pub/Sub, Scripting, Modules,
and now Streams in
Redis 5.0, which
is pretty powerful when it comes
to processing streaming data.
And when we talk
about use cases,
obviously there are all
kinds of different use cases.
The very common ones that
we see at least in what we
have seen with memory store
is obviously the first,
I would say four,
are pretty common.
So caching, straight
up query caching.
Session store is very,
very common with Redis.
So essentially
you basically want
to have your session
stored in Redis.
And rate limiting, we have a
lot of customers basically using
readies Redis for
API rate limiting.
That's one of the common
use cases that we see.
Fast ingest is an
interesting use case
where you can use various
data structures within Redis
to basically quickly
process streaming
data into your pipeline.
So when you look at these
use cases, like I said,
there are different
data structures
that you can use to basically
support these use cases.
I think most of you are
probably very familiar with it
if you're already using Redis.
I'm just listening a few.
Session store, like
for example, HASH
is a very interesting
data structure in Redis.
HASH essentially allows
you to basically take
a set of key values
and basically
put them in a higher
level data structure.
And it's like very
memory efficient.
So one of the things
that we recommend
is if you are using essentially
just plain key value,
it's probably a lot
of key value pairs,
it's probably better
to take a look
and see whether you can
convert that into HASHes,
because it's very
memory efficient.
Sorted set is also
very powerful.
Sorted set, essentially, it's
a mapping of member's scores
that allows you to easily
sort through the scores
and basically give
you, hey, what is
a top ten for example, player.
Or the top 10 players
in the game, et cetera.
So I'm not going to
go deep into those.
I just want to give you
a quick overview in terms
of why Redis is so popular.
And it looks like a lot of
you are already using Redis.
So the interesting
thing about it,
when you move to the cloud,
one of the key benefits
that everybody wants
to get is that you
don't want to manage your own
application infrastructure.
That is fundamentally
one of the key benefits
that everybody's looking for.
So from a database
portfolio perspective,
you probably will see the
slide through many sessions.
But the point is that we
offer a variety of databases,
as managed services.
So Cloud Memorystore is our
managed in-memory data store.
And it's essentially
managed Redis.
And I'll talk more about Cloud
Memorystore going forward.
And we also have the
Non-relational databases
of Cloud Bigtable, which is our
wide column store, obviously
Cloud Spanner, which is
our distributed relational
database, BigQuery, which
is our data warehouse.
And the other thing, if
you listen to the keynote,
one of the things that
we are also trying to do
is to work very closely
with our partners
and make sure that if there are
capabilities that the partner
ecosystem provides,
you can easily
get that from Google Cloud
in a very integrated manner.
So the bottom line here is that
there's a portfolio of services
that we provide and
the key goal for us
is to provide it as
a managed service
so that you don't
have to do the work
in terms of managing
these infrastructure.
All right, so let's dive into
the core of the talk which
is Cloud Memorystore.
This a high level I would
say marketing slide.
But the key point
here is that there
are three things that we
try to optimize for when
we run this managed service.
One is, it's going to
be fully managed by us.
So what that means is
that any kind of patching,
security vulnerabilities
that come from Redis,
et cetera, we
automatically take care of.
We probably have already done
two security patches already
that comes from Redis.
We get notified even
before you get to know.
So we take care of all that.
The other thing that
we really focus on
is this availability and
reliability of the service.
For me as a product
manager, I keep
telling my team that reliability
is our number one feature.
And because that
is fundamentally
what you expect us to do from
a managed service perspective.
So when it comes to
reliability, I'll
talk about the
different offerings
that we have and the
kind of capabilities
that we provide with
Cloud Memorystore.
But the key thing is
that we use replication.
We have automatic Failover and
we also provide SLAs around it.
And the last thing,
last but not the least,
from a security perspective,
we have various capabilities
that we provide to make sure
that the system is secure.
And I'll talk more about
the details of that.
So Memorystore, if you're
not using Memorystore,
Memorystore comes
in two flavors.
One it's what we
call the basic tier.
And that's essentially a
standalone instance of Redis.
So standalone
instance, so if you
ask the question,
what do you get
with that standalone
instance, we essentially
take care of all the
health monitoring.
We take care of the automatic
recovery from failures.
The other thing that we also
do is that IP preservation.
So in case the system goes
down and comes back up.
You are guaranteed
to have the same IP.
So from an application
perspective,
you don't have to
worry about IP changes.
The standard tier is the
replicated Redis instance.
What we provide
with standard tier
is a cross zone
replicated Redis.
So we have a Redis instance that
is replicated at cross zones.
We automatically take
care of the failover,
and it's a single endpoint.
So we essentially
have a virtual IP that
is in front of the instance.
And when failover happens
or the node back and forth,
you're essentially
connecting to a single IP.
So there's no IP change
when that happens.
And we allow you to scale
up and down seamlessly.
And I'll walk through
the demo and show you
how this works in
actuality, in the demo.
But we also provide three
nines of availability
for the standard tier service.
And the other thing that I want
to kind of quickly touch upon
is that the way we have exposed
servers, essentially, is that--
Redis is a single
credit service.
So what we have essentially
done is behind the scenes,
we tiered the service, meaning
the more memory you provision,
you get more network throughput.
So behind the scenes,
what's happening
is that we adjust the number
of CPUs, every provision,
depending on the
size of the instance
that you're provisioning.
So the higher the memory,
the higher the throughput.
That's a provisioning model.
And I'll show that in the demo
in terms of how that works.
So we went GA about
six months back.
And we've been doing a lot
of work behind the scenes
to provide more features.
So we have Redis 4.0
currently in beta.
We are working on 5.0 too.
The other thing that we
are enabling as of next
is the ability to
access Memorystore
from App Engine Standard,
2nd generation runtimes.
How many of you use
App Engine at all?
Does this matter?
Or is it useful?
Yeah, so again, the point
that I want to make here
is that it's only
for 2nd gen runtime.
So if you're using App Engine
Standard 1st generation
runtimes, obviously that
only supports App Engine SDK.
Memorystore releases
both Redis' protocols.
So if you're using
2nd gen runtime,
you can essentially
connect to Memorystore.
The other thing that we've
been asked quite a bit
from customers is the ability
to test your application
before you deploy,
especially when you're
using standard tier instances.
So one of the things that
you want to be able to test
is the failover, the behavior
when the service fails.
So we have exposed the
manual failover command
that you can use to test your
service before you deploy it.
We added a bunch of
new monitoring metrics.
We have learned a
lot since GA in terms
of how customers are using it.
So we are exposing
more and more metrics
to help you understand how
your system is behaving
and how you want
to react to that.
So that best practices
section, we'll
actually walk through each of
these metrics and more of some
of the things that you should
be monitoring and watching out
for.
And lastly, we've been
continuously adding regions.
We are pretty much
all over the--
pretty much in
all regions except
maybe like three or
four, which we probably
would roll out pretty quickly.
And then we are continuing
to work on our compliance
and support for Memorystore.
So this is probably
interesting for folks
who haven't used Memorystore.
So I just want to walk
through the product
and give you an overview,
but at the same time
answer some questions that
aren't certain characteristics
of Memorystore.
So Memorystore
essentially is listed
under the storage portfolio
in Google Cloud Console.
And it's pretty straightforward.
I think we made it pretty
simple to go and provision
a Redis instance.
I'm just going to
create one right now.
So from a version
perspective, we
recommend that you
start using 4.0
if you are going to start
using Memorystore now.
We support both 3.2 and 4.0.
We are currently
beta, but we will
go GA pretty much
in like a few weeks.
But we highly recommend that you
start using 4.0 going forward.
And this is where I was
talking about the tiers.
You can select either
basic or standard tier.
Just going to select
standard tier.
So what happens in the standard
tier essentially is, Redis--
Memorystore is a
regional service, what
we call a regional service.
So you can pick any region
that you want to deploy to.
So as you can see, we're pretty
much in most of the regions
today.
And the zone essentially
you can leave it at any.
And we will pick
the zones for you.
Is there any reason
anybody need to pick
a zone in your use case?
Like specific zones
for a Redis instance?
So yeah.
So we recommend just
leaving it at any.
And we will just pick
the zone for you.
From a capacity
perspective, this
is where essentially you
size your Redis instance.
And as I mentioned, if you
look at the network throughput
as you provision
more memory size,
you get more network throughput.
The other important
aspect to remember
is the security model
for Cloud Memorystore.
So today, the security
model we have essentially
is that we only expose Cloud
Memorystore using private IP.
And the other security
authorization that you can have
is that you can restrict
the access to a specific VPC
in your project.
So that's the current
security model.
We understand that
there are cases
where you want to be able to
have much further restriction
at the instance level.
So that's something
that we are working
on enabling, to
have instance level
authentication for Memorystore.
How many of you require
instance level auth?
So the notion here is that
if you are authorizing
just the VPC network, that
means pretty much any VM that
is connected to that VPC
network and that project
can access the Redis instance.
So that's pretty much it.
And if you go into
the advanced options,
we have exposed a few of the
Redis configurations here.
We haven't exposed all of them.
And this is something
that we tried
to do intentionally in terms
of exposing the config.
But we exposed the main ones.
The key one that you want
to just watch out for
is max memory policy.
The max memory
policy by default,
we set it to volatile LRU.
I'll talk more about the
eviction policies later on.
But that's something
that you want
to be super aware of in terms of
what is a default that we set.
And that's volatile LRU.
That's it.
So you click create, oh shoot.
I should use this.
You click create, and
that's pretty much it.
That's all you need to do to
provision a Redis instance.
And once you provision,
you basically
get the management capabilities
right here on the console.
We have essentially
a list of metrics
that'd be exposed in
the console itself
that you can use to monitor.
But the recommendation is
that you use Stackdriver
for monitoring
Cloud Memorystore,
because we exposed a lot
more metrics in Stackdriver
compared to the console.
And Stackdriver also gives
you additional capabilities
like alerting, et cetera.
So we will have a
demo in just a bit
to just talk about the
different capabilities
or different monitoring
metrics that we have,
and what are some of
the things that you
want to watch out for when
you monitor Memorystore.
How many of you use Shared
VPC in your environment?
Nobody?
OK.
The concept of Shared
VPC is something
that you probably
will run into if you
start using GCP a lot more.
So the concept is that you can
basically share a VPC network
across multiple projects.
There's a concept of a host
project and service project,
meaning if you are, let's say,
from a dev ops perspective,
you wanna be able
to give autonomy
to individual
application teams, you
can basically create
multiple service projects
and share this common
network across all of them.
So in that particular case,
it's one of those things
that if you want to deploy
Cloud Memorystore into one
of those service projects, that
is currently not supported.
That's one of the things
that we are working on.
So if you have that
particular use case,
that's something that we
will enable pretty quickly.
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN: And
a good example of that
I want to mention real quick.
We have customers
who want to set up
a demo environment, or sorry,
a dev or test environment,
where they share
Memorystore instance
across multiple applications,
or multiple versions
of the application.
A Shared VPC would be
useful in that case.
GOPAL ASHOK: So one of
the other important points
that I want to make with
where we are with Memorystore,
is that both basic tier
and standard tier instances
are single master.
So that becomes an
interesting thing
to be aware of,
because obviously Redis
being single threaded,
there are certain thresholds
that you will hit pretty
quickly if there's
a single master based
on your workload.
So the solution for that
obviously is Redis clustering.
We haven't enabled
Redis clustering yet
in Cloud Memorystore.
So that's something, again,
that we are working on.
So that's something that
you need to be aware of.
And I've seen this a few
times where customers
look at standard
tier and they expect
it to be a scale out model.
But in this
particular case, it's
just a highly available Redis
instance with a single master.
Has anybody deployed
Redis cluster today
by yourself in GCP?
So now what I want
to do is I want
to touch up on some of the
best practices around when
using Cloud Memorystore.
So when I look at
best practices--
and this kind of spans mostly
best practices around Redis--
and there are some
specific things
around Cloud
Memorystore that you
want to be aware of when
you are using the service.
So when you look at the
best practices around Redis,
I see three, I look at it
as three buckets of things.
One is, there are
things that you
can do in terms of storing
data where you can do things
to do things more efficiently.
The other one is how do
you manage your evictions?
And that kind of ties into
also the memory management
aspects of Redis.
And finally, monitoring,
that's something
that we want to talk
about very specifically
on Cloud Memorystore, because
there are certain things
that we do from a managed
service perspective that
will be useful for
you to understand,
that will help you to manage
your instances better.
From storing data
perspective, there
are a lot of very good
recommendations out there.
I just wanted to touch
upon like three things
that we find very useful
from a Redis perspective.
I think one of the
things is that if you
can compress the data,
whenever possible, do that.
So there are very good
libraries like Google
has a snappy library that
you can use to compress data.
So that's a very good
way where you can,
depending on the kind of
data that you store in Redis,
you can even get up
to 50% compression.
So that's one of the things
that you should definitely
look into when you are
using even Memorystore,
because Memorystore behind the
scenes uses open source Redis.
So any best practices
that applies
to open source Redis also
applies to Cloud Memorystore.
The other one that
we see quite a bit
is that in terms of using
the right serializer.
Java serializers are
notoriously inefficient.
So there are some very
good serializers out there.
Google's Protocol
Buffer is one way
to serialize the data more
efficiently, even if you want
it stored in a binary format.
So that's one of
the things that you
want to take a close
look at, again,
in terms of how you store data.
Because again, it's
all about how efficient
you can be in terms of memory,
because memory is expensive.
And the more data you store,
that can quickly add up.
And I mentioned this before
using HASH data structure
to reduce memory
usage is again, it all
depends on the kind of
data that you're storing.
But I think the key point
that I want to make here
is that it's important for
you to look at it from a Redis
perspective and apply the best
practices that you would apply
for Redis if you were
deploying it on your own,
even when you are using
Cloud Memorystore.
So I think that's the
key point that I'm
trying to make here when
it comes to best practices
on storing data.
Eviction policies are
very, very important.
And it's something that you
have to be super aware of.
And eviction policy is
all about how you actually
want to store data, and how
long you want to store data,
combined with how much money
you want to spend, in a way.
So fundamentally, eviction
policies, as we all know,
is essentially
the rules that you
apply to evict data
from Redis memory
based on certain
characteristics.
So there are basically two
groups of eviction policies.
There is the-- or
I would say three.
There is no
eviction, which means
that it's essentially
like a fixed memory size
that once you hit
the memory limit,
Redis is not going
to evict any data.
And essentially Redis is
basically going to say,
we can't store anymore
data in your instance.
Then there's all keys
and volatile base LRUs.
The volatile LRU like
I said, essentially is
what we enable as a default.
And this is something
that we recommend.
It's an interesting
conversation when
it comes to eviction policy.
How many of you set TTLs
in your Redis instance?
OK.
So the interesting
thing about volatile LRU
is that if you
don't set the TTL,
then that essentially
means that there is
no piece that can be evicted.
So that's an interesting--
But at the same
time, volatile LRU
is a more efficient way
to manage your memory,
because it essentially allows
you to set a TTL and evict,
or at least expire the
keys once you hit the TTL.
But that requires a little
bit more understanding
of your usage patterns
and how much--
what the keys are
used for, and how long
you want the keys in
memory, et cetera.
But that allows you to
basically be a little bit more
efficient in terms of memory
and how large of an instance
you want to provision.
All keys LRU, on the other
hand, essentially what
it says is that once
you hit the max memory,
it's going to basically evict
the least recently used keys.
But it basically is going
to fill up the memory
and then start evicting keys.
So there are some
interesting consequences
of doing all keys LRUs
versus volatile LRU,
and we'll talk about that in
our monitoring best practices.
And Redis has recently
introduced an LFU policy,
where it's a little bit more
efficient algorithm than LRU,
where it's all
about how many times
you have access to the keys.
So LFU.
So that's also an interesting--
compared to a LRU, or
similar to LRU, again,
you just need to have a
very good sense of how
your keys are being used.
And then using LRU
or LFU will actually
help you with better
memory management in Redis.
The other key thing
is, how many of you
said you are using
Cloud Memorystore?
Have you guys run into
memory fragmentation issue
on your side?
So we take care of that.
So memory fragmentation is
a real problem in Redis.
It's again, like I said, if you
are using open source Redis,
you will run into memory
fragmentation problem.
And what essentially, what
memory fragmentation is,
it's basically Redis has
a concept of max memory.
That is essentially
the memory that you
set for the Redis process.
But the way Redis
allocate memory,
Redis can actually
consume more memory
than what is allocated
for max memory.
So it will essentially
creep into the system
memory that you
provision, or the access
memory that you provision.
And at some point, you will
run out of system memory.
And that will cause a crash.
The reason memory
fragmentation happens
is for a few different reasons.
If you have very
homogeneous keys then
the memory allocation
is pretty homogeneous
when you use the
[INAUDIBLE] operator.
But if you have
varying size keys,
then it's quite
possible that you
will run into a
high fragmentation,
or there's more
chance of running
into high fragmentation.
So when high
fragmentation happens,
there's a bunch of
memory that is unusable.
And then we quickly
get into a situation
where Redis has to consume
more memory than what
is allocated for Redis.
And then you get into that
issue of basically running out
of system memory.
And that can
potentially crash Redis.
So one of the key things that
you want to watch out for
is have things in
place that will
allow you to detect
memory fragmentation
and take action on it.
So our best practices
demo, we will
walk through what is that
you need to watch out for,
because there are
only certain things
that we can do from a
managed service perspective.
There are things that we
do from a managed service
perspective to ensure that your
systems are up and running.
But there are also
cases where you
want to be proactive about
not getting into a situation
where you have high
memory fragmentation.
This problem was
actually worse in 3.2,
but in 4.0 they have introduced
active de-fragmentation
so that when the
instance is running,
there's a background thread that
basically de-frags the memory.
This comes with a
cost of a higher CPU.
So this is something
that you basically
want to turn on and see
for your workload what
the CPU overhead is.
But based on
everything that we have
seen in the community and the
testing that we have done,
it seems to be a safe
thing to turn on.
But again, depending
on your workload
you want to monitor your
CPU when you do this.
So monitoring fragmentation
and taking action
is one of the things that if
you start using Memorystore,
you absolutely should
know how to do that.
And even if you are
not using Memorystore,
from a Redis perspective, it
is important to understand
what are some of
the metrics that you
should be monitoring to make
sure that your system runs
in a very stable manner.
So let's go over that.
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN: Just
switch over real quick.
GOPAL ASHOK: Oh sorry.
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN:
It's all good.
GOPAL ASHOK: So let me quickly
walk through the Stackdriver
monitoring.
If you haven't used
Stackdriver before,
so Stackdriver is Google
Cloud's monitoring platform.
So it's like Cloud
Launch for EWS,
if you're familiar with a EWS.
So in Stackdriver,
what he can do
is you can essentially
go look for metrics.
So in this particular
case, you can say Redis.
And we have exposed a lot of
metrics related to our Redis
over here.
So there's a lot of metrics
that you can monitor.
But the question is, what are
the right metrics to monitor.
The baseline set of metrics
that you want to monitor,
and what are some of the trends
that you want to watch out for.
And that's what we want
to talk about here.
So what we have done is we have
created a couple of dashboards
here.
Let me just go back.
So what we have
here is an instance
where we are running a
benchmark behind the scenes.
We are running a
[INAUDIBLE] benchmark.
So what we are
essentially doing is,
we have created an instance
with the basic default eviction
policy, which is volatile LRU.
And we have set the time
to live to be very short.
So in this particular
case, as you can see,
the max memory is set to 10 GB.
So the first graph
is essentially
a graph with the max
memory and use memory.
So the system is actually
running pretty stable
right now.
So there is enough memory
available for Redis to consume.
But that's one
graph that you want
to monitor to ensure that
your memory consumption is OK.
The next graph, which is the
system memory usage ratio
is something that
we just released.
So this is essentially
the graph that
tells you how much fragmentation
do you have in your system.
So system memory
usage ratio, what
we do when we manage services is
that Redis obviously requires--
when you provision
a Redis instance,
you obviously require
some overhead to take
care of known data set.
And Redis a whole bunch
of background threads
and operations that they do.
So there is a recommendation
of, you need to provision
some system memory
over max memory
to make sure that
the system is up
and running in a single fashion
so we take care of that today.
But the thing is that
you need to be able to--
even then, there
will be fragmentation
that happens in your system.
So when you monitor
system memory usage ratio,
essentially what
you are looking for
is you want to look for
whether the graph is
trending towards 100%.
So based on the overhead that
we provision behind the scenes,
your system use and
memory usage ratio
will always start
at a percentage.
Typically it's going to be
around 60%, which is fine.
Because that's based on
the amount of overhead
that we provision
behind the scenes.
But the key thing that
you want to watch out for
is what is a trend as
your workload peaks
and over a period of time,
whether it's trending towards,
let's say 70%, 80%, 90%.
So that's a key graph to watch.
Bytes pending
replication, again,
is a very interesting thing that
you should always watch for,
because Redis replication
is asynchronous.
And depending on
your right load,
you can obviously have a--
depending on the right load,
and the kind of instance
that you have, you can have a
pretty big replication backlog.
And this is just
the nature of Redis.
So what that tells you is
whether your instance is
able to sustain the workload
that you have running
on that particular instance.
The consequence of bytes
pending replication going high
essentially is that it can
also drive higher memory
consumption.
But also Redis can
get into this behavior
of doing a full synchronization
once the bytes pending
replication go below
a certain limit.
So that's again
another key graph
to watch out for
when you are doing,
just managing Redis in general.
But all these metrics
are exposed for you.
So you can just use
Stackdriver to do that.
The other interesting
one is keys, the number
of keys versus expirable keys.
It's a good thing to understand
in terms of, hey first of all,
if you're using
volatile LRU and if you
don't see expirable
keys that's a bad sign.
That means you haven't
really set TTL,
and you either should
set a TTL or you
should change your eviction
policy to all keys LRU.
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN: Can
you scroll down, actually
scroll down.
GOPAL ASHOK: A few
more things that you
want to watch out
for is, obviously
CPU network throughput is a
good one to just keep an eye on.
And evicted keys,
you can understand.
So for example, if you
run into memory pressure,
and if you're not
seeing an eviction,
that's something that you
want to go take a look at.
The failover one is
also an interesting one,
because there are
scenarios where
we have to failover the
instance without you knowing
or triggering just to make
sure that the system is
in a stable state.
So it's very good to know
whether if multiple failovers
happen in a period of time.
And that can also
have consequences
to your application because
when we do a failover, obviously
we disconnect the clients.
So if you are running into
behaviors or scenarios
where you're like,
why is my application
getting disconnected,
or if there
is some kind of
inconsistency when you're
running a job, for example.
If you do a failover,
because Redis replication is
asynchronous, there could
be stale data or potentially
loss of data when that happens.
So monitoring if failovers are
happening in your environment
is a good way to understand
if some of the application
behavior that is happening
is due to the failover that's
happening in the system.
If you see a lot of failovers,
in Cloud Memorystore, that
means there's
something going on.
And we will know about
it, we'll take care of it.
But it's important for you also
to know that that's going on.
So these I would say
are the key metrics
that you should be
monitoring regardless
of whether things that are
bad or happening or not.
When you provision
Memorystore, you
should be just monitoring these
metrics in your environment.
Let's take a quick look
out of their graph,
same set of metrics.
But the interesting thing here
is that we ran this benchmark
and we set a long TTL.
And that's essentially
what I'm talking
about in terms of the
system memory usage ratio
keep going up.
I think we saw the
benchmark at some point.
But if you continue to run that
benchmark for the instance size
that we had, we
essentially would
have hit the system memory usage
ratio of 100%, at that point,
we will failover.
And we will try to keep
the system up and running.
But in some cases,
it can get extreme
where we are not able
to, or the system
is not able to recover itself.
So that's the
reason we recommend
that you monitor your
system memory usage
ratio to be around 80%.
Set an alert in Stackdriver.
And the action that you can
take at that point, essentially
is to scale your instance.
So that will
essentially give you
more memory for the workload
that you're running.
So that's a very important
graph to keep an eye on and also
put some alerts on.
So I talked about monitoring
system memory usage ratio
and then triggering an alert.
The question is,
and I also said, OK,
do you want to do scaling?
So one of the--
so the question is, what is
an efficient way to do it.
Karthi, do you want
to talk about it?
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN: Sure.
So as we were kind of
working through this demo,
one of the things we
wanted to showcase
is the fact that in
addition to the reliability
that you get with Cloud
Memorystore for Redis,
as opposed to running
Redis on your own
is the GCP ecosystem of
services that you get to use.
And this is a good example of
that where as Gopal mentioned,
you look at these trends,
for example, system memory
ratio, and other things.
As they trend in a direction,
you want to take action.
You could take action manually,
or you could automate it.
And this is one way to do it.
The reason we want to talk
about doing it this way
is because it's
fully serverless.
And serverless is all the rage.
You're not standing up separate
VMs and things like that.
And this counts on the fact
that Stackdriver is essentially
a giant time series database.
So you can inspect the
metrics that you're
interested in inspecting,
for example, the ones
that Gopal pointed to.
And you can do that
on a scheduled basis.
As I'll show you,
we're going to do it
once every minute,
sample the metrics
that we're interested in kind
of seeing the trends for.
And then based on
how they're trending,
you can actually use a Cloud
function to scale up your Cloud
Memorystore for Redis instance.
And this is because
we give you an API.
Just like with every
service that GCP has,
Cloud Memorystore has an
API to initiate a scale up.
So you can automate this.
So let's look at
that real quick.
If we could switch
back to the demo.
So I mentioned the
Cloud Scheduler service.
This is a service that
we recently released.
You don't want to stand up a
VM and run [INAUDIBLE] on it.
You want to use a
reliable service for this.
The way this works is you
can set up this service
to generate a Pub/Sub message.
And then in this case, we're
going to do it once a minute.
And then based on the
Pub/Sub message getting
deposited into a topic, you
could run a Cloud Function.
And I'll quickly talk
through this Cloud Function.
I don't want to take
up too much time.
I hope there are folks who--
or most of the folks in this
room hopefully know Python.
Essentially what
we're going to do
is check to see if our
system memory usage
ratio is trending up rapidly.
And that is up to you to decide.
And then another thing we
have to pay attention to,
if you remember, we were
tracking the bytes pending
replication.
We want to make sure that this
is not some crazy number where
it's like 8 gigs behind.
You don't want to trigger a
scale up event at that time,
because you might
have data loss.
So you have to balance this.
And what we would
recommend is, try
to get ahead of the
situation, where
if you're seeing
growth early on,
and you know the growth
is going to continue on,
then trigger this kind
of scale up event.
And then at that point you
decide how much to scale up by.
In this case I just
randomly picked two.
And you call the
scale up function,
which uses the Cloud Memorystore
for Redis Python SDK,
and basically sets the memory
size to the new value that you
would like it to have.
Of course, you want to
make sure that you do this
with some boundaries in
mind, because obviously we
have a limit of 300 gigs.
And you may have some limits
in terms of budgets and things
like that, keep that in
mind when you automate it.
But it is recommended that you
automate this within reason.
GOPAL ASHOK: All right.
Thank you very much.
It was a pleasure
talking to you all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]